hello everyone good morning welcome to
Pi data Seattle
this presentation is called quantifying
uncertainty in Time series forecasting
with conformal prediction we are in the
Saint Helens room
our speakers today are fed a and Max
they are both co-founders of nisla and
we will in this presentation we'll be
exploring the use of conformal
prediction in the context of Time series
analysis so please welcome philliam Max
[Applause]
hello can you can you hear me it's the
mic okay great
so I'm Max I'm co-founder of Nick's lab
this is fare feather uses the non-binary
pronouns they hit them and I use their
binary pronouns he him today we're gonna
be speaking about a conformer prediction
for time series and the outline of the
talk is as follows we will Begin by
stressing the importance or motivating
the importance for time series analysis
and time series forecasting then we're
going to show you how to perform
scalable time series forecasting
pipelines with machine learning methods
and at the end of the talk we're gonna
address the problem of quantifying
uncertainty
um let's let's start with the hype and
with the hot topic that everyone is
speaking about as you're very well aware
chat gpt4 has a new API and that was
amazing also mid-journey has released
some incredible technology to treat
images and videos and generally speaking
it seems that this new wave of large
Transformer models are making great
breakthroughs in text language videos
and image but what about temporal
temporal tabular data What About Time
series and in this particular case it's
not clear how a big foundational model
would look look like and that's
precisely one of the things that we are
researching at nixler we believe that
time language and perception are the
necessary conditions for experience they
are the necessary conditions for
intelligence generally speaking the time
temporal Dimension is essential to
understand anything that has to do with
change with growth with okay and we're
trying to build those foundational
models for a Time series
and we think this is particularly
interesting and relevant because first
class citizens of the world like
businesses institutions and even systems
they don't speak in language in in
images or language they they speak data
and they speak normally a Time series
we're trying to create that technology
to understand classify and predict Time
series
so for one second close your eyes and
open them and thanks to the magic of Pi
data Seattle now you are the minister of
tourism in Australia and
you get a lot of questions asked but one
of the most important one is how many
tourists are going to be visiting the
country next month next year and this is
important because your colleagues at the
transportation office asks you how
should I staff the airports how many
people should I put at the security
lines how many people should be in the
control Towers but also your colleagues
at the other Departments of State they
ask you how will the economy grow
related to the inflows of different
tourists in the country
and this this is a classical example of
an important time series problem here in
the screen you can see some graphs on
the y-axis you have the number of
tourists that are visiting particular
regions of Australia and in the x-axis
you have the time the last 15 years so
you have the different values for
tourism inflows in Australia for
different regions and what you're trying
to do is based on the past and based on
certain exogenous variables like weather
or special events or economic relations
of New Zealand which might be a
competitor in in the tourism inflows
you're trying to predict the future
the good thing is that you can't use a
machine learning method to forecast
thousands and even millions of Time
series and today we're going to show you
how you can do that easily with a
library an open source library that we
created called ml forecast ml forecast
is part of the time series ecosystem
that we are building everything that we
built is is licensed under the MIT
license so it's completely free to use
you can do and build whatever you want
you can build if a commercial products
if you want that's that's fine we have
been trying to address the whole
landscape of Time series not only
machine learning but also statistical
methods and also newer neural
forecasting methods that are trying to
solve the questions that I post at the
beginning regarding foundational models
in the field so how does my ml forecast
work we we built this library trying to
create a simple scalable fast interface
for you practitioners to to interact
with it and in reality the only thing
that you have to do to start building
we're going to start with a linear
regression as a baseline is to to import
the ml forecast class from the ml
forecast package you have to import in
this case linear regression from a
psychic learn we support and natively
interface with all models of psychic
learn so you can import whatever model
you want in this case we're using a
classical model for time series called
linear regression but you could use
nearest neighbors or support Vector
machines or MLPs or whatever then the ml
forecast class takes a list of models in
this case we're using the linear
regression you specify the frequency of
the data in this case we have monthly
visitors in in Australia and then you
can specify date features like year
month that might be important for the
models to to understand then you call
the classical
scikit-learn API interface with the fit
and predict methods you just pass the
data frame this data frame match
but it could also be a spark data frame
it could also be a task data frame
thanks to to the partnership that we
created with the folks at fuch we
support basically any data frame which
is very exciting once you start having
very large scale data the The Columns
that you need the the minimal column
that you needs are the ID that specify
the different uh the unique ID of the
data the date column or the time column
as we call it and the target variable
that you are trying to forecast we also
support exogenous variables and the only
thing that you have to do if you want to
predict
um the next 12 a month that is the next
year you just call the dot predict
method of the ml forecast class
but ammo forecast is also very powerful
we established a pipeline on how to
create a linear regression but we might
want to do and include other powerful
methods like xgboost or light GBM so
that sounds hard and maybe it would take
us a lot of code but thanks to the
interface that we created you just have
to import those models make them part of
the list and with those I think 20
characters now your pipeline supports
not only one but three or n different
models that you can compare against ml
forecast is also very flexible if if you
have worked in machine learning and in
particular with time series data you
know that feature engineering feature
creation lacks Transformations are are
excuse my French but here are pain in
the ass normally and and we try to
simplify that by making them available
inside the main ml forecast class so for
example let's assume you want to do some
Target transforms because you have to
you want to scale the data or you want
to take out the difference every 12
steps to take out the yearly seasonality
and and have the models render better
performance the only thing that you have
to do is import those Target transforms
and inside the ml forecast you can pass
that as an argument in this case we're
going to take the 12 step difference and
we're gonna do a min max scalar so the
model performs better so in just three
lines of code inside the same pipeline
that supports all the different models
that I showed you now we're doing uh
starting to do interesting feature
engineering what about lags if we wanted
to include lacks like uh the last 24
lakhs to this that is the model for for
the model to learn the last two years
the only thing that we have to do is
pass the Lux argument and we can start
doing Transformations on those lags so
in this case we're doing the expanding
mean for the last month and the rolling
mean and the expanding mean for the last
year and for the last two years which is
a 12th and the 24th observation so again
in a couple of flies inside the same
class you can have very scalable robust
and simple pipelines ammo forecast was
built from the beginning with
scalability and speed on mine all the
optimal station functions that we used
are optimized using number just in time
compiler which makes it very very fast
and it's also optimized for a
parallelism the the training and the
prediction of the models support a
parallelization not only inside a single
node but thanks to our native interfaces
to spark desk and Ray
joules thank you for being here
we support a high scale computation
which is which is amazing because now
you are not horizontally bounded by a
speed or by storage you can horizontally
distribute your workloads using
wonderful Technologies like like Ray a
ml forecast is also tested one of the
things that we like to do is Benchmark
the things that we published and this is
there is this very famous data set
called the M5 it's Walmart data for
different years and different products
and we recreate it in a Kegel notebook
that you can reproduce by yourself and
use demo forecast to achieve one percent
or rank it the one percentile so one of
the top submissions in under three
minutes using the four CPUs that kaggle
supports natively so it's very fast it's
very efficient it's very powerful we
have also tested against other Solutions
like AWS forecast where 24 percent more
accurate than them in the same data set
and 400 percent faster and we have also
tested against profit and and we are far
better so
back to our problem we started with this
time series and we wanted to predict the
future now we used ml forecast it took
us a couple of lines it ran very fast
and we're doing a wonderful job as
Ministers of Tourism so it seems that we
are very happy and can work can keep
working on our political campaign
but we start getting asked more
questions so not only how many tourists
are going to be visiting Australia but
how many are going to be visiting in the
best case worst case scenario at the end
of the day was the range of possible
visitors in the future
and this is important not only for
people working in Australia doing
tourism but generally speaking for
retail or generally speaking for
everyone that is doing optimization
inventory or staff so imagine that you
are running
a an airport and if you have more people
than you need then you simply have a
little bit of cost for those extra
salaries or wages if you have less
people that you need and more tourists
come that you expected then the lines
start getting saturated you lose your
flight and it becomes a whole cows so
it's a lot better to be a little bit
above than a little bit below the the
forecast and that's what we call
different quantiles but also in in
retail if you have a little bit more of
inventory then then it's fine you simply
store it or pay the extra production
cost if you have less inventory to
satisfy the the potential demand then
you're losing a lot of money in Lost
opportunity sales so it seems that we we
really need to have a distributions
another question could be have there
been any unexpected behaviors maybe some
event that had some important uh
consequences on the inflows of Tourism
and that's what we call anomaly
detection and a very simple way of
defining an anomaly is every value that
lies above or Beyond a certain threshold
of the distribution that you are
forecasting and this is important
yesterday the the people that lift gave
a talk on how to do anomaly detection
using a stats forecast another library
of nyxla to do almost real-time anomaly
detection
the problem is that we just have Point
forecast what I showed you with the ammo
forecast is just a single point we don't
have any distributions
and we need prediction intervals if we
want to start optimizing and answering
the three questions that I just showed
you
so it seems that things are not that
fine
hopefully feather can now help us solve
that problem he promised that he will
help us Define those intervals for for
the forecast and I hope he he does
and thank you very much Max
um so far we've created a lot of
forecasts for different time series and
then and and then we want to to quantify
the uncertainty of those of those
forecasts so what are prediction
intervals
so basically a prediction interval gives
you an interval within which we expect
the three values to lie with a certain
probability so for example if you want
to produce a 95 prediction interval we
we want that the True Values will lie in
in that interval 95 of the time
and this concept is it is a really key
concept it is called calibration so
basically we are measuring the
probability of the the correctness of of
our model
so we have we have a problem and the
problem is that machine learning methods
can create prediction intervals natively
we need to produce a technique to to
calculate those intervals and an initial
approach could be just use the
multi-quantile loss and the
multi-quantile laws allows you not just
to estimate the mean of the of the
forecast but also quantiles of the of
the forecast and if you include that
loss in your in your model you will be
creating a lot of quantities not not
just one
what is the problem with the
multi-quantile loss approach in general
it produces uncalibrated forecast here
in the example we we want to produce a
50 probability a prediction interval and
then we are calculating the 50
um the 75 and the 25 quantiles and we
can see that the the quantiles are
crossing so the forecast the the
forecasts are not calibrated
an alternative approach would be just to
use statistical methods the main problem
with the with those methods is that they
also produce uncalibrated intervals so
for example here we are seeing a Time
series which exhibits a clear seasonal
pattern each 24 hours and the first
thing we notice is that the mean or
Point forecast is just a straight line
and also we can see that the prediction
intervals becomes wider as long as the
Horizon increases so if we know that
there is a clear seasonal pattern our
forecasts are not capturing that so this
is a this is a problem another problem
with the statistical methods is that
they assume normality so in order for us
to calculate the prediction intervals we
need to know the two parameters of that
distribution the mean and the variance
and once we have that we can use that
formula to calculate the prediction
intervals so it is a really a really
hard problem because with with the
traditional approaches we are
calculating the mean the mean
um parameter of the random variable but
we also need to calculate the variance
and it is really interesting because if
because we want to or we need to
estimate the uh that pair of parameters
for all the Horizon so for example if
you want to predict 12 steps ahead we
need to calculate a 12 pairs of
parameters not just one
what is the solution and the solution is
conformal prediction so basically
conformal prediction allows you to use
any kind of Point forecaster and and use
it to calculate a prediction intervals
um one of the main characteristics of
this approach is that it
theoretically guarantees that the
prediction intervals are well calibrated
also you don't have to assume any kind
of distribution so for example in the
statistical methods we are assuming
normality but in this case we we are not
assuming anything
another interesting thing about this
approach is that we don't have to assume
any pre or prior probability for example
in contrast with with a Bayesian
approaches
um so basically with conformal
prediction we want to construct a an
interval which is well calibrated by by
definition
how can we do that using time series the
main idea behind conformal prediction is
that we can estimate the distribution of
the errors of our model and once we have
that distribution we can calculate the
quantiles associated to the distribution
and after that add those quantiles to
the mean to the mean estimate and after
that we will have the the prediction
interval so how can we estimate the
distribution of Errors to do that we can
use cross validation for time series
forecasting so basically we can split
the data in different Windows
considering the temporal index of of our
data and then we we can forecast
different values for different windows
in in our time series and and then once
we have the forecast and the actual
values we can compute errors and those
errors will give us the the distribution
or expected this distribution of them of
the of the errors how can we Implement
conformal prediction for time series
forecasting fortunately ml forecasts
includes this feature natively so you
just have to include one additional
argument to the fit method and the
prediction intervals argument and it
receives a prediction intervals class
which receives two main arguments the
number of cross-validation Windows we
want to use to calculate the errors in
this case we are using only for Windows
and also it receives the forecasting
Horizon in this case we want to predict
the the next 12 months so the
forecasting Horizon is 12. so after the
fit method we just have to call the
predict method and we we need to define
the level of our prediction intervals in
this case we are generating two
prediction intervals one of eighty
percent and the other one with 90 90
percent
so after that uh with just a couple of
lines of code we we have included
prediction intervals to to our to our
forecast and as you can see some series
exhibit a clear seasonal parent and the
model and the the prediction intervals
Associated to those to those series are
are narrower and and another and when
the series is sparse or exhibits uh more
Randomness uh the the prediction
intervals becomes wider
so that's it in in a couple of lines of
code we we were able to create
calibrated forecast for thousands of of
Time series using using machine learning
and thank you
[Applause]
you moderate or we moderate uh either
way please okay so I love that you
sent you a list of models as an option
for the input here ml forecast does that
mean that there is Ensemble capabilities
or is it strictly comparing the outputs
of each of these models and if so how
are you comparing the outputs today
determine goodness of it
one one of the paradigms that we have in
the whole NYX levers ml4cast.forecast
and oral forecast is once you specify
the list of models the output is a data
frame that contains in each column the
results of the models and if you have a
prediction intervals the model and the
prediction interval so creating and
samples is really easy the only thing
that you have to do is for example sum
the column light GPM and HQ boost and
divide it by two and you would have a
mean and Sample in in one line so so we
give you all the different forecasts for
all the different models so you can
either compare them or Ensemble them or
do specific choices so that's that's up
to you or up to the practitioner to to
Define
what
can you hear it back back there should
we pass like yeah sorry
uh
no no worries
um I've done a lot of Time series work
using like the
profit library but mostly like the darts
time series library and
there's a lot of I think overlap between
what you guys are doing and what they're
doing and
I guess you mentioned that there's a
performance benefit to using nyxla when
the underlying models are all kind of
like the same right like XG boost and
like the whatever regression models and
darts has stuff for like using grid
search to
find the right features and things like
that and conformal so I guess what's the
comparative benefit and what are you
guys doing that's different
that's a very good question
um and actually darts uses a lot of the
models that we have created I think what
we're doing differently in the whole Nix
lab project is try to build everything
from the ground up not really we don't
identify as a library that is wrapping
pre-existing models but that is actually
creating new models or new
implementations of classical models that
are very optimal in this particular case
the ammo forecast is an interface to
pre-existing models of the SK family and
like via manicure boost but stats
forecast for example it's a library
where we took the classical
implementations of Hitman from the r
ecosystem and ported them to python
rewrote them in a very efficient way
wrote Our Own optimization methods like
the nelder mid and that's what makes
makes it very very fast so it's a lot
faster than PMD arima and actually most
of the most used statistical methods of
darts ETS arimas exponential smoothings
thetas are our own implementations and
on the other side on the neural
forecasting side of things we're also
publishing and researching new models
and proposing new models and some of
those models are included in darts for
example the nbtx which is a paper that
we co-author with with variouskin or the
end kit those models are integrated in
darts so I guess the main difference
that I would say is on the one side
focusing on original efficient
implementations and on the other side
what we think it's a particular or
extremely different is that we natively
built this to scale horizontally if you
try to scale with profit with darts with
SK time with and all of those wonderful
libraries by the way
you're going to have a lot of problem
scaling them they don't natively support
horizontal multi-cluster or multi-node
scaling so in my opinion that's that's
one one important difference but I don't
know if you want to add something there
thank you
can you pass the money yeah
option
thank you for that presentation it was
awesome so you mentioned that for
building the conformal predictor you use
cross-validation and then use that for
determining the distribution of Errors
is that the way it works can can you
elaborate it on in on it a little more
yes sure so so basically that is the
main the main idea and in particular for
time series forecasting we don't want to
estimate the distribution of all the
errors but we want to estimate the
distribution of each step in the Horizon
so for example if we want to predict 12
steps ahead we were we will be
calculating the the distribution of the
first step and the second step and so on
so the the technique is is learning to
quantify the uncertainty not for the
fall for for the full Horizon at once
but for each step in the in the horizon
got it thank you
so because this method doesn't make an
assumption on the shape of the
distribution you learn from data
do you have
uh requirements in terms of the data set
size so that you can estimate that
distribution accurately what's the
consequence on the size of the data set
that's needed for accurate prediction
yeah that's a really a really good
question I I think the main the main
idea behind behind conformal prediction
is that you need to calculate errors so
if you have a lot of data you can you
can use that technique because you can
information right so I would say that if
if you have more more information that
that would be best yeah
and and
there is a specific number that's uh
like minimum requirement but that number
it's going to be empirically determined
by the specific data set that you have
so sadly we don't have like an a
priority General answer but yes
obviously if you have very few
observations you would like to use those
observations as much as possible to
train your model and not to evaluate the
model so it's this classical bias
variance problem that you have on this
classical data set size that you have
there was someone yeah
real quick
uh thank you the library looks really
cool
um I was just curious if
um you currently support or planning to
support like time series models from say
tensorflow just as an example or other
other kind of like you know iconic
libraries that are that are used for
time series besides sklearn
yeah sure that's an interesting question
and we support neural forecasting
methods in our library neural forecast
and it is written in in torch I think
it is one of the main Frameworks for for
for deep learning and we we
explored a tensorflow but at the end of
the day we we end up using
um by torch and by touch lining because
it it is really easy to to to use and
and it is really fast
and and maybe that's also one one
difference between what we are doing and
other other paradigms from the very
beginning we decided to split the
Paradigm so if you are using statistical
forecasting methods then obviously you
don't need the whole dependency Health
that comes with more complicated
Frameworks and that's why we decided to
make it different libraries obviously
you can handle it with different methods
but that's why why we decided to do it
that way but yes in neural forecast
which is a python a pytorch lighting
base or Pi torch based Library you can
easily bring your own models as far as
they satisfy the pytorch paradigmund and
have a similar structure and and it in
our opinion it's quite easy if you are
interested in bringing in models that
come from other
researchers that's easy that's for
example neural forecast now supports not
only our own research but also research
that has come out at the Amazon or
Google like tfts and and other other
methods
oh thank you for the for the talk
um I was curious whether or what you've
done in the area of um regarding to time
series where the area distribution would
change with time
uh because it seems like the conformal
prediction sort of requires that that
distribution is constant
yeah that that's an interesting and
important and important question and and
I would say that I just
um
explained before the the main idea
behind behind conformal prediction is
that exactly you can estimate the
distribution of the errors but if there
is a drift in the in the data and you
and you
could use that data to to calculate the
distribution of the errors we we should
expect that that drift will be will be
captured by the by the by the technique
so so the
the main
um
I would say
I would say that you need to to identify
that the drift of your data and then you
can use that technique on that that Rift
of that change and and the technique we
will be capturing that that that change
yeah would you like to
just
we have been asked that question a lot
like how to handle a regime changing
time series data and we're working on
certain models that are better suited
for those specific needs maybe maybe
some like early attempts that you can do
and where we're about to publish that is
using the Arts and guard family of
models in the statistical library and
right now we don't support conformal
prediction there but one of our next
releases is gonna include conformal
prediction for all the statistical
methods so maybe for some specific
reading changing time series the whole
Arch family might provide a good a good
Baseline plus conformal prediction but
we are we're working on that it's a very
important topic
I think
we've probably got time for two more
questions
get this out of the room real quick
thank you thanks for the presentation
my eyes I pretended there was a minister
of Australia
but what was the outcome how did the
library perform what was my decision in
logic
can you guys can conclude that please
thank you very much
thank you very very much so the the
outcome is that you were able to do
wonderful forecasts for the different
regions and also Quantified the
uncertainty and you are probably running
for office and becoming president of
Australia after your wonderful job as as
minister of Tourism
uh thank you very much again I think
there was a question there yes
I think we can also handle the last
question quick question uh do you do we
need to rename the columns like dates DS
or something like that
you don't need to rename uh rename them
if you for example instead of why use I
don't know sales you can
um you can Define with uh with our
parameters
um what are you what are you training on
so for example if the target call
instead of Y is sales you can include
the the sales
um the sales column and exactly the same
for all the other parameters yeah
so the only thing that is required is
that you have at least one ID at least
one timestamp and at least one like
value that you want to forecast but you
can map it to whatever names you have
can I use Simple forecasts to do
multivariate forecasting like for
instance if I want to forecast energy
consumption for the next five days I
could use historical data but I also
wanted to add the weather component to
it can I can I use it absolutely
if the method supports it you can use as
many exogenous variables as you want and
all the methods that we showed support
exogenous variables uh so so yeah
definitely you can include the weather
you can include price you can include
like the index of certain Commodities
that might influence the consumption of
energy and that's definitely going to
give you some a boost in accuracy
we're also working on on Strictly
speaking multivariate problems where
you're trying also to measure the
relationship between the different
series and not only the relation between
the covariates of a specific to a
specific series and you can you can find
those like General multivariate methods
in neural forecast
someone else I think we have time for
one more
we tried to keep it brief so we we got
time to answer more questions
thank you yeah thank you for the talk I
have a question uh regarding the
distribution of the editor I think we
just discussed so um
is it better to remove outlier in that
perspective like what's your take on
outlier
yeah sure in our experience that
improves a lot
the width of the conformal intervals and
also you can instead of removing the
outliers transform your data to to to
make it more smooth so for example you
can use uh box Cox transformation and
and you can you can make the time series
smooth so yeah it is usually a good
practice to take into account the
outliers of the data yeah
but what if like those outliers is
somewhat meaningful because I always
kind of get confused when it comes to
forecasting like is it actually like
those outlier has like some meaning in
the data so like how do we like handle
those situations yeah that's that's
interesting one one of the the ideas
that usually improves the forecast and
takes into account the outliers is to
include them for example as a exogenous
variable so for example if you know that
in a specific day there was a a huge
amount of sales due to I don't know
maybe because it is December or
something else you can include that
dummy variable and then you you you you
could tell to the model here is an
outlier but I can explain why it is an
outlier so it will improve the the
forecasting accuracy and also the the
prediction intervals yeah
[Music]
we have some Nixa stickers for you if
you want
uh can we give a big round of applause
for Max and Petty